en general nos hemos dedicado a resolver
integrales que no sean tan difíciles de
resolver y que salgan con una
sustitución trigonométricas en esta
ocasión tengo una integral un poco más
difícil de hacer la cual a simple vista
nos sale por sustitución esto porque no
tenemos la derivada afuera de la raíz
sin embargo tenemos una raíz cuadrada y
algo elevado al cuadrado por lo tanto
suena un poco lógico hacer una
sustitución trigonométricas y bueno
además el nombre del vídeo dice que va
por ahí sin embargo en esta ocasión
adentro de la raíz no tenemos las formas
comunes que son 1 - x cuadrada x
cuadrada menos 1 o x cuadrada más 1 con
las cuales hacemos nuestra sustitución
trigonométricas por lo tanto que es lo
que vamos a hacer y bueno para ello a
resolver este enigma y este problema
primero déjenme borrar esto que tengo
aquí para ahora sí pensar que es lo que
podemos hacer entonces vamos a quitar
esto que tengo aquí esto que tengo acá y
esto que tengo acá y ahora si regresemos
a pensar en el problema original en esta
integral yo tengo una x cuadrada por lo
tanto lo que voy a intentar hacer es
fijarme en lo que está dentro de la raíz
para yo poder escribir en él
forma de lo que ya conocemos
habitualmente para hacer mi cambio de
variable por lo tanto primero voy a
escribir el -5 después voy a poner un
signo de menos y voy a hacer más grande
mi raíz y después voy a pedir un
paréntesis boyas actualizar 19 menos
entonces menos por equis cuadrada me
queda menos x cuadrada y después voy a
tener que menos x menos me va a dar más
más 6 x que era 6x que teníamos
originalmente ahora lo que voy a hacer
es completar el binomio al cuadrado
perfecto que yo tengo aquí adentro de
estos paréntesis me va a quedar cuadrado
del primero menos dos veces el primero
por el segundo y después le tengo que
agregar el cuadrado del segundo es decir
el cuadrado de 3 que es 9 sin embargo yo
acabo de agregar este 9 por mis
pantalones y como no puedo agregar
cualquier número adentro de mi raíz lo
que tengo que hacer es que se elimine
sin embargo aquí 169 menos menos por más
me da menos entonces es menos 9 y para
que se elimine pues le voy a sumar 9 y
ahora si se va a eliminar porque más 9
menos 9 me va a dar 0 y todo esto se
multiplica por de x y antes de proseguir
quiero que se den cuenta que no he hecho
nada nuevo
tengo el menos x cuadrada aquí tengo él
6x y aquí tengo el menos 5 y después
tengo un más 9 y un -9 que se cancelan
me dan 0 por lo tanto lo que hice fue
agregar un 0 el cual me va a ayudar a
resolver de una manera mucho más
sencilla esta ecuación porque que me va
a quedar bueno menos 59 me da 4 y x
cuadrada menos 6 x más 9 es lo mismo que
x menos tres elevado al cuadrado factor
izando esta expresión que tenemos aquí
arriba me queda x menos 3 elevado al
cuadrado y ahora si lo voy a escribir de
nuevo para que vean cómo me va quedando
todo por lo tanto tengo la integral de
la raíz cuadrada de 4 - y en lugar de
poner x cuadrada menos 6 x + 9 voy a
poner el binomio x menos tres elevado al
cuadrado y todo esto lo voy a
multiplicar por de x y tened en cuenta
que poco a poco ya se va asemejando más
a las sustituciones trigonométricas que
he hecho es más para que se parezca más
lo que voy a hacer aquí adentro de esta
raíz es factorizar el 4 me queda 4 que
multiplica a 1 menos
x 3 todo esto elevado al cuadrado entre
4 lo único que hice fue factorizar el 4
y darse cuenta que estas dos expresiones
son lo mismo 4 por unas 44 entre 4 me da
1 entonces me quedaría x menos tres
elevado al cuadrado y todo esto por de
equis y bueno la raíz de 4 se puede
hacer esto es lo mismo que la raíz de 4
que multiplica la raíz de todo lo demás
y la raíz de 4 es 2 y como es una
constante entonces me queda dos veces la
integral de 1 - x le voy a poner mejor
así de x-men 2 3 entre 2
todo esto elevado al cuadrado
diferencial de x y bueno volvamos a ver
que estas dos expresiones son iguales x
menos 3 elevado al cuadrado me quedaría
arriba y en el denominador me va a
quedar 2 elevado al cuadrado que es 4
por lo tanto ya pasamos de esta
expresión a esta expresión que yo tengo
aquí la cual se asemeja mucho a uno de
todos los cambios de variables que se
hacen cuando hay sustituciones
econométrica a cuál me refiero al que
dice coseno cuadrado de teta es igual a
uno menos el seno cuadrado de teta como
ya tenemos una expresión que se parece
mucho a ésta
es que un cuadrado de teta se iguala a 1
- x menos tres elevado al cuadrado o
dicho de otra manera x 3 entre 2 elevado
al cuadrado tiene que ser igual al seno
cuadrado de teta y ese va a ser mi
cambio de variable para ello poder
resolver esta integral entonces lo que
quiero es que x menos 3 todo esto entre
2 elevado al cuadrado sea igual al seno
cuadrado de teta sea igual al seno
cuadrado de teta ahora lo que voy a
hacer es sacar a raíz de ambos lados de
la ecuación y si saco raíz me queda que
este cuadrado se va y me queda x menos 3
entre 2 y del otro lado también se va al
cuadrado y solamente me queda el seno de
teta y recuerden que cuando hago este
tipo de cambio de variables
lo primero que necesito hacer es
despejar la teta y para ello lo voy a
poner aquí el ángulo teta va a ser igual
y voy a pasar el seno del otro lado de
la ecuación me queda teta es igual al
ángulo cuyo seno o al arco cuyo seno es
x menos 3 entre 2 al arco seno de x
menos tres entre 2
y también por otra parte lo que necesito
es despejar a equis necesito despejar la
x porque con ello voy a poder calcular
la diferencial de x entonces para esto
voy a ponerlo de este lado de la
ecuación y me va a quedar que voy a
pasar primero el 2 multiplicando por lo
tanto tengo x menos 3 es igual a dos
veces el seno de teta y después me
estorba este 3 por lo tanto lo voy a
pasar sumando x es igual a dos veces el
seno de teta más tres y esto lo hago
porque también necesito la derivada de x
con respecto a teta por lo tanto me
queda que la derivada de x con respecto
al ángulo teta que es dos veces la
derivada del seno de teta el cual es el
coste no beteta más la derivada de tres
con respecto a teta es decir cero o
visto en su forma diferencial la
diferencial de x es igual a dos veces el
concepto de teta diferencial de teta y
ahora sí ya tengo a theta ya tengo a x
ya tengo a de x vamos a sustituir y que
me va a quedar dos veces la raíz ya
dentro de la raíz yo tengo uno menos
toda esta expresión y esta expresión era
ni más ni menos que el seno cuadrado de
teta haciendo mi cambio de variable
entonces me queda dos veces la raíz d
1 - el seno cuadrado de teta x de x pero
la diferencial de x es toda esta
expresión que tengo aquí es decir 2
veces el concepto de teta diferencial de
teta y ahora lo segundo que voy a hacer
es quitar esta raíz una vez porque 1 -
el seno cuadrado de teta es el coste no
cuadrado de teta esto por la identidad
pitagórica y después la raíz de esto
pues la raíz de un cuadrado se van y
entonces me va a quedar que toda esta
expresión que yo voy a tener aquí de
color naranja todo esto que yo tengo
aquí es lo mismo que la raíz del coseno
cuadrado de teta y después el cuadrado
con la raíz evans y me queda simple y
sencillamente el concepto de teta
positivo debido a una razón que habíamos
visto en vídeos anteriores por lo tanto
me queda dos veces toda esta expresión
que tengo aquí que es el coseno de teta
por todo esto que tengo aquí que es dos
veces el coche no detecta diferencial de
teta lo voy a poner con colores esto de
aquí es esto de aquí esta expresión de
café esto de aquí es dos veces el coche
no detecta es esto de aquí y después al
final tengo que agregarle que está
multiplicando todos estos dos factores
entonces me queda dos veces el coche no
detecta por dos veces el coste no
detecta diferencial de theta lo cual es
la integral de cuatro veces el coste no
cuadrado desde atrás diferencial de teta
ahora aquí viene lo entretenido de este
asunto porque resolver está integral del
coste no cuadrado de tetas diferencial
de teta parece ser muy sencillo sin
embargo no lo es esta integral nos sale
por sustitución para resolverla hay que
acordarnos de una identidad
trigonométricas que vimos hace tiempo la
cual va a ser muy útil para poder
resolver el problema esta identidad
decía lo siguiente el coche no cuadrado
de un ángulo es igual a un medio que
multiplica a uno más el coseno de dos
veces es el mismo ángulo esta identidad
de econométrica nos va a servir bastante
para poder resolver esta integral porque
el coste no cuadrado va a ser todo esto
de aquí y la prueba de esta identidad
trigonométricas le habíamos visto
bastantes veces en alguno de mis vídeos
anteriores por lo tanto busque la tienen
que ver con el ángulo doble y entonces
me queda 4 que multiplica a un medio que
a su vez multiplica a uno más el coche
no es de dos veces teta y todo
diferencial de teta lo único que hice
fue sustituir el coseno cuadrado de teta
ahora vamos a buscar un poco más de
espacio y cuatro por un medio me da 22
que multiplica a 1 más el concepto de
dos tetas diferencial de teta y con este
cambio de variable van a ver que ya
resolví todo este problema porque me
queda ahora sí voy a distribuir el dos
me queda dos más dos veces el coseno de
dos tetas y todo esto multiplicado por
de teta la primera integral es muy
sencilla es la integral de dos de teta y
la integral del segundo sumando también
es muy sencilla porque hay que recordar
cuál es la derivada del coche no no no
no pues la derivada con respecto a teta
del seno de dos teta
pues la anti derivada de dos veces el
coche no de dos teta es el seno de dos
tetas
si yo derivó el seno de dos tetas edad 2
que multiplica a la derivada del seno
que es el coche no de dos tetas
por lo tanto ya tengo la solución dos
por de teta integral es dos veces teta
más la integral de dos veces el coche no
de dos tetas diferencial de teta por lo
que acabamos de ver es el seno de dos
tetas
esto hay que agregarle nuestra
famosísima constante de integración más
una constante de integración y ya he
resuelto esta integral en términos del
ángulo theta ojo me falta hacer la
sustitución hacia atrás para encontrar
esta expresión en términos de x sin
embargo yo sabía que teta es igual al
arco seno de x menos 3 entre 2 y como
esto es muy importante lo voy a apuntar
aquí el ángulo theta es igual al arco
seno de x menos 3 entre 2 ahora si yo
sustituyó a theta en esta expresión pues
al principio me queda bien padre pero
después yo tengo el seno de dos veces
teta y me quedaría algo como el seno de
dos veces el arco seno de x menos 3
entre 2 lo cual no es nada elegante ni
nada divertido por lo tanto lo que voy a
intentar hacer a continuación es
escribir todo esto en términos del seno
de teta mi intención es escribir el seno
de dos teta con algo que tenga que ver
con el seno de teta a secas sin el 2
porque porque lo que yo estoy viendo es
que el seno y el arco seno son funciones
inversas por lo tanto se pueden cancelar
porque si yo logra hacer esto me va a
quedar
siguiente el seno de eta pero quién es
el centro sería el seno del arco seno de
x 3 entre 2 el seno del arco seno de x 3
entre 2 pero el seno y el arco seno son
funciones inversas por lo tanto se
cancelarían y me quedaría x menos 3
sobre 2 y esto ya se ve muy elegante y
una expresión matemática muy amena por
lo tanto tras lo que voy a escribir el
seno de dos veces teta como una función
solamente del seno y bueno para esto voy
a recordar otra identidad
trigonométricas que era muy importante y
que también había probado en vídeos
anteriores mi otra identidad
trigonométricas que voy a usar en esta
ocasión me dice que el seno de dos veces
teta es igual al seno de teta mastretta
es decir el seno del ángulo doble y si
hacemos un poco de memoria esto me queda
el seno de teta por el coste no de teta
más el seno de teta por el coseno beteta
porque es un ángulo doble y buenos en
nueve t tacos 39 tetas en 9 t tacos en 9
teta pues como son iguales me queda dos
veces el c9 teta coseno beteta
y ahora sí ya tengo algo que tiene que
ver con el seno de teta cuando empezamos
con algo que tenía que ver con el seno
de dos veces teta así que vamos
reemplazando poco a poco para ver a
dónde vamos oa dónde llegamos me queda
dos veces esté tan más el seno de dos
teta pero esto es lo mismo que dos veces
el seno de t tacos de nueve teta más mi
constante de integración y bueno ahora
lo que voy a intentar hacer es escribir
también el coseno como función del seno
y para esto pues voy a recordar la
identidad trigonométricas más importante
que hay es decir que el coste no
cuadrado es igual a uno menos el seno
cuadrado de teta o dicho de otra manera
el coche no de teta es igual a la raíz
de uno menos el seno cuadrado de teta y
esto para que para escribir el coseno
también como una función del seno y se
pueda cancelar el seno con el arco seno
por lo tanto esto me va a quedar dos
veces teta que le suma a dos veces el
seno de teta por el coseno beteta pero
el coche no de teta es la raíz de uno
menos el seno cuadrado de teta uno menos
el seno cuadrado desde eta más la
constante de integración y ahora sí ya
que tengo todo escrito en términos del
seno de teta
voy a hacer mi cambio de variable y mi
sustitución hacia atrás el seno de teta
habíamos dicho que era x menos 3 entre 2
y theta era el arco seno de x menos 3
entre 2 por lo tanto me queda dos veces
theta dos veces teta es dos veces y
theta es el arco seno de x menos tres
entre dos por lo tanto me queda dos
veces el arco cuyo seno
x 3 todo esto dividido entre dos más dos
veces el seno de teta pero el seno de
teta habíamos dicho que es x menos 3
entre 2 a secas por lo tanto me queda
dos veces x menos 3 entre 2 que
multiplica a su vez a la raíz de uno
menos el seno cuadrado de teta es decir
la raíz de uno menos el seno cuadrado de
teta que es x menos 3 entre 2 todo esto
elevado al cuadrado x menos 3 entre 2
todo esto elevado al cuadrado más mi
constante de integración y bueno ahora
lo que voy a intentar hacer es
simplificar un poco toda la expresión
que tengo aquí lo que quiero es que me
quede muy elegante todo esto hoy me voy
a lucir entonces me queda dos veces el
arco seno de x menos 3 entre 2 más 2 con
el 12 van y me queda x menos 3 que
multiplica a la raíz de y aquí tengo uno
menos x menos 3 entre 2 elevado al
cuadrado por lo tanto primero voy a
desarrollar este cuadrado que tengo aquí
me queda uno menos
x 3 elevado al cuadrado esto lo voy a
poner al cuadrado y abajo me va a quedar
4 y bueno ahora que sigue dijo que la
simplificación de todo esto me está
quedando más grande de lo que pensaba
pero ahora lo que se me ocurre hacer es
multiplicar todo esto por uno por un uno
especial voy a multiplicar por 2 sobre 2
entonces voy a poner aquí todo esto lo
voy a multiplicar por 2 entre 2 y me van
a decir pero sal porque estás haciendo
todo esto cuál es su intención al
estarnos complicando más el asunto o no
que acaso te has vuelto loco pero yo lo
que quiero es que puedan meter un dos
uno de estos dos aquí adentro de la raíz
para que se pueda ver todo de una manera
mucho más parecida a la integral
original es decir esto me queda dos
veces el arco seno de x menos 3 entre 2
y aquí voy a poner x menos 3 sobre 2 es
este 2 que estaba dividiendo y esto va a
multiplicar a su vez y este 2 que tengo
aquí lo voy a meter adentro de la raíz y
como meto un 2 adentro de una raíz pues
como raíz de 4
entonces me queda la raíz de 4 que
multiplica a la raíz de 1 - x menos 3
elevado al cuadrado entre 4 más mi
constante de integración y bueno ahora
voy a seguir simplificando si yo tengo
la raíz de 4 que multiplica a la raíz de
1 - x menos tres elevado al cuadrado
entre 4 que me va a quedar entonces voy
a escribir todo como ésta tal cual todo
esto más x menos 3 entre 2 y ahora sí me
queda pues el 4 lo voy a meter adentro
de la raíz y voy a agarrar una raíz en
común es decir 4 por 1 4 y 4 entre
cuatro me va a dar 1 y por lo tanto
solamente me queda menos x menos tres
elevado al cuadrado
ahora voy a elevar esto al cuadrado
entonces me queda dos veces la coseno de
x menos 3 entre 2
las x 3 / 2 por la raíz de quien bueno
me queda 4 - y esto de aquí es x
cuadrada menos 6 x + 9 todo esto más la
constante de integración y bueno todo
esto que está aquí quién crees que sea
pues va a ser la expresión original
porque me quedan 6 x positivo y después
me queda menos x cuadrada y después me
queda cuatro menos 9 es decir menos 5
todo esto es lo mismo que está escrito
aquí arriba adentro de la raíz por lo
tanto el final me va a quedar dos veces
el arco seno de x menos 3 sobre 2 más x
menos 3 sobre 2 que multiplica la raíz
de quién de 6 aquí lo voy a poner con
otro color de 6 x - x cuadrada menos 5
más la constante de integración y ya por
fin tengo la anti derivada o la solución
de mi integral original de la integral
con la que empecé con esta que yo tenía
aquí es decir de la integral de quien
era del a
es de 6 x x cuadrada menos 5 diferencial
de x y seguramente tú estás tan cansado
como estoy yo la verdad me duele la mano
de escribir tanto pero date cuenta que
acabamos de resolver una integral que no
era tan sencilla de resolver y te debes
de sentir muy orgulloso de ello